[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER PATNOE: Hi there.
Thank you for joining us
today with a conversation
on accessibility and AR/VR.
Today, we're going to have a
quick overview of AR and VR,
just to provide some
background for those people who
aren't familiar.
Then we'll share some
inclusive design principles
and guidelines.
And then finally, we'll
review different disabilities,
sharing some opportunities on
how to make your applications
and experiences more inclusive.
My name is Christopher Patnoe.
I'm a senior
program manager here
on Google's central
accessibility team.
I've spent many years working
at Apple, building hardware,
software, Sony Ericsson, making
phones, even Disney Mobile,
making games.
I've been at Google for over
six years, where I worked on
Google Play Music and even
Daydream, our AR and VR
platform.
I spent the past four
years in a 20% role
working in accessibility.
And in the past year,
I've been able to make
my side hustle my day job.
RAN TAO: And hi.
My name is Ran Tao.
And I'm a software engineer
on the AR core team,
as part of Daydream.
I joined Daydream
last year, summer,
after I graduated
from UC San Diego
where I studied computer
graphics and computer vision.
I have been using a wheelchair
full time now for two years.
And I'm passionate about
promoting accessibility
in Daydream and in the AR
and VR industry as a whole.
So before we dive into making
AR and VR more accessible,
let's first have
a quick overview
as to what is augmented
and virtual reality.
Here's how we think
about these technologies.
We have VR, where the
world is hidden from you
and the virtual
content surrounds you.
VR can take you anywhere.
And we have AR,
where you still see
the real world and
virtual objects
are superimposed on top.
And so AR brings things to you.
And let's talk about VR first.
There's so many headsets
out there right now.
And the industry
is growing rapidly.
At Google, we've developed
Cardboard and the Daydream
View.
And we partnered with Lenovo
to make the Mirage Solo.
These three headsets
have a key distinction.
So the two on the left there,
Cardboard and Daydream View,
they have three degrees
of freedom tracking, which
means you can rotate your
head in any direction
and look everywhere.
The experience is
kind of like a movie
projected on a
sphere around you.
And you're in the center of that
sphere, so you can look around.
But you can't really lean
in closer to any objects.
And then we have the Mirage
Solo with WorldSense,
which allows for six
degrees of freedom tracking.
That means not only
can you look around,
you can also move forward,
back, up, down, left, right.
And this allows for a much
more natural interaction,
where you can duck when a
snowball is thrown at you.
Over the past few years,
since Google's launched
the Cardboard, so many
experiences have been created.
You've probably heard of games
like Job Simulator or apps
like YouTube VR.
My personal favorite
is Street View, where
I can go anywhere in the world.
They even have 360 photos up
on the International Space
Station.
And there's also artistic apps
like Tilt Brush and experiences
for meditation training
and so much more.
And let's now move
on to AR, where
we can bring things to you.
So Google's ARCore SDK, which
just launched this year,
allows you to create these
experiences in Android, Unity,
and Unreal Engine.
These AR experiences
cover similar areas to VR.
And you can also do fun
things like adding stickers,
like the storm trooper here.
Moving along now.
CHRISTOPHER PATNOE: So
bringing in the concept
of inclusive design,
many people ask, well,
what is inclusive design?
Well, to me, it means being
mindful in your choices
so that you don't exclude
someone accidentally
by a lack of thought.
The way I got involved
here in accessibility
is when I was on
Google Play Music.
A test engineer came up
and brought her device
and a speaker, plugged them in.
I heard button,
button, button, button.
And I'm seeing people
smile here, because you
know what this means.
But I didn't at the time.
What this means is that the
application was not accessible.
So I asked, what is this?
And she said, well, this
is your application.
I said, well, that's stupid.
How does someone use it?
And she said, this
is why I'm here.
And it was at that
moment that I realized
that it takes zero effort
to make your experience
or application not inclusive.
It only takes a little
bit to make it inclusive.
So that's what we're
here to talk about.
And accessibility is
one of the key lenses,
one of the most tangible
lenses for inclusive design.
Well, why is
accessibility important?
Well, one, it's the
right thing to do.
And two, it's
potentially big business.
There are more than
one billion people
in the world who have some
form of disability, about 15%.
About one in five
people in the US
will have a disability at
some point in their lives.
Just to give you
another sense of this,
there are more than 300 million
people who are colorblind.
That's more people who
are colorblind that are
people of the United States--
and I think that's
important to remember,
is accessibility is a spectrum.
It's not a binary on, off thing.
Many common
ailments, you may not
recognize have
[INAUDIBLE] disabilities
is like nearsightedness,
arthritis, or even a bad back.
And there are still lots of
nuances within these groupings
of disabilities.
It's more like cups
instead of buckets.
Because as there are
individual people and people
have different abilities,
people have different kinds
of disabilities.
And they're very subtle.
But fortunately, the things
that help these different groups
bring up all the boats up
together at the same time.
You also want to think about
situational or temporary
impairments like a broken leg
or carrying a bag of groceries
or even using your
device with bright sun.
All of these things are
situational impairments.
And finally, different people
learn at different speeds,
either by disability
or simply stress.
So the core thing I want
you to come away with is
don't design for yourself.
Design for the broadest
possible markets.
And you'll be surprised
who you're supporting.
How do you do this, do you ask?
Well, I'm glad you asked.
One of the ways
I talk about this
is a thing called the curb cut.
What a curb cut is is
that part of the sidewalk
that is dipped down, usually
in the corner of blocks.
This is designed to allow
people with wheelchairs
to be able to get up
onto the sidewalk.
That's really
profoundly important.
But it's also really useful
for people with suitcases
or bicycles or baby strollers.
So the idea of a
curb cut is something
that can help many
people, but it's
profoundly impactful,
profoundly impactful
for people with disabilities.
Another example, if
you had to help address
the needs of someone
who is hard of hearing,
you're also helping people
who forgot their ear buds.
And just so you know, this
means captions, for example.
You're helping people who
forgot their ear buds.
You're helping people
on a noisy train,
or conversely in
a quiet room where
you don't want to make
a lot of noise, or even
non-native speakers.
This one accommodation can help
lots of people, more people
than you might realize
at the beginning.
Another example.
And here's one that's
really close to my heart,
or maybe many of you here.
If you're stuck in
an airplane seat--
and some of you may have been
in an airplane quite recently--
you put on a headset and
something happens behind you.
But you're strapped in.
You can't get around.
Well, what do you do?
Well, one curb cut is
something that the Google Earth
team solved.
They actually rotate
the world around you.
So you actually can have
what's happening behind you
be moved into the front.
Also, YouTube VR has solved
the same kind of problem
by rotating the
world around you.
So this way, you've improved
the world for people
in wheelchairs, airplane
seats, or even your comfy bed.
There are few standards today
in terms of accessibility
around AR and VR.
In fact, they are none.
So here's an opportunity to
really do something exciting
that could really
impact people's lives.
Even before AR, people
were using devices
to help improve their lives.
People were using their
cameras on their cell phones
to magnify something.
Well, this is actually
an assistive device
called a magnifier.
But people didn't realize they
were using assistive tech.
They were just using their
phone to magnify something.
And it makes their life better.
That's the whole idea.
But now, with modern
AR and VR, you
can fly anywhere in the world.
So someone who was stuck in
bed can visit the International
Space Station.
Or you can measure the
couch in your room.
Or if the game is
designed as such,
you can sort of
see when someone's
shooting from behind you.
Or how about when
you're stressed?
You can have the
most important piece
of information highlighted
or have everything else
be ignored for you.
This is pretty
useful for everybody.
And fortunately,
each of these things
are also profoundly impactful
for people with different kinds
of disabilities.
And there's a lot of
ways that AR and VR
can help people, perhaps
in ways you don't expect.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Throughout my career,
I've had the opportunity
to care for children and
young adults with cancer.
And seeing the
difficulties that they have
and the anxiety
that they develop,
when I watch them
put on the headsets,
you can see immediately the
change in their body language
and their facial expression.
- Wow.
- My husband tried Tilt Brush.
- That was a great deal of fun.
- Subsequently, he went
and bought art supplies.
He took classes.
- It took my mind away from
just passively experiencing
something.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRISTOPHER PATNOE:
Research is being done today
that shows that VR can actually
help people feel less pain.
And it can change
people's lives,
introduce a new skill or talent
they never knew that they had.
A wise man once said,
with great power
comes great responsibility.
So how do you start?
Well, one place to start
is by with trusted experts.
For over a decade, AbleGamers
have helped countless gamers
with disabilities either return
to games after traumatic injury
or start playing games,
despite a disability.
They've either worked
with Sony and Microsoft
to add accessibility settings
into their platforms.
And they've come up with this
concept called includification,
which comes in a
free 48-page PDF.
And many of the
ideas from this talk
come from this
includification concept.
RAN TAO: Let's dive
into a little bit
about what works today.
So on the right there, you see
the new Android O accessibility
options and what it looks like.
Many of the settings work
right out of the box.
Don't worry about trying
to read it though.
It's kind of small.
So here's the highlights.
There is color and
contrast adjustments,
color corrections for different
types of color deficiencies.
So my little brother has
trouble differentiating
between red and green.
He has a hard time
telling who's the enemy
team, who's the ally team.
So he's just shooting
around on the phone.
And he actually turns on
this color correction mode
and it helps him a lot.
Turning on these settings
automatically applies it
to the AR and VR apps.
We also have mono
audio, which mixes
the right and the left
channels into a single channel,
and then puts those two
channels into both the earbuds.
So you can watch videos
with just a single earbud.
And this also
works in AR and VR.
We also have magnification,
where you triple tap on
the screen to zoom in.
And this works
really well in AR.
And then we have Switch
Access and TalkBack,
which I'll get into.
So designing for accessibility,
things that you can do today?
Well, Switch Access and
TalkBack requires the app
to support Android
accessibility APIs.
This is where you come in.
The APIs are in Java, so you can
integrate them into your Java
or C++ apps.
The switch access makes
it possible for people
with dexterity impairments
to use your app
with one or more switches.
These switches can take
the form of buttons,
like the volume buttons
on the side of the phone,
or special sensors.
Like, Stephen Hawking had
sensors that detected his cheek
muscle twitches.
So with one button,
you can press to cycle
through the different
items, like you
see that blue box highlighting.
And when you get to
the one you want,
you press the second
button to select it.
And then we have
TalkBack, which is
another way you can use to
interact with your phone.
But I'll let my friend Victor
show you how he uses it
in a simple tic-tac-toe app.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My name is Victor
Tsaran and I'm
a technical program manager
on the Android Accessibility
Services team.
Among other products,
we work on TalkBack.
TalkBack is a screen reader
for people who are blind
or vision impaired.
The way you use TalkBack is
via special touch gestures.
The output, the feedback,
is provided by speech.
- Tic-tac-toe.
- There are two ways
you can navigate
the screen with TalkBack.
The first one is called
linear navigation
and is performed by swiping left
and right with a single finger.
When the element of
interest is located,
the user double taps
on it to activate.
- Next placed in center.
O's turn.
O placed in bottom left.
Empty space button.
X's turn.
O's turn.
O placed in bottom right.
- Another method is
called touch exploration.
In this method, you
direct the finger
across the elements
on the screen.
Once the element of
interest is located,
you double tap on
it to activate.
- Column two.
Empty space button.
X placed in center left.
X wins.
[END PLAYBACK]
RAN TAO: Awesome.
I'm glad he won.
That tic-tac-toe app uses
graphics that are rendered
in OpenGL in C++.
And it allows Android
accessibility APIs
to interact with them.
If you want, you can check out
the code at github.com/zork.
And accessibility should
not be an afterthought.
This is taken from a
recent trip to Japan.
And in Japan, they have a lot
of older houses and businesses
where they
retrofitted with ramps
to make it more accessible.
And this ramp here, I don't
know if you can tell or not,
is like a 45 degree angle.
So if I even tried
to go forward,
I would just tip forward.
Interestingly
enough, my girlfriend
that took this picture,
as she was trying
to get back up that ramp,
she just kept slipping
and couldn't even get up.
So not sure what's
happening there.
This is another one.
I still don't understand
what those are for.
So start thinking
about it today.
Start testing,
talking, and listening.
Your users have a lot to say.
Test your apps in
suboptimal conditions
with limited capabilities,
like with bright sunlight
or a noisy environment or
holding a cup of coffee
in one hand.
Understand your users' needs by
reaching out to the community.
Reach out to friends
or friends of friends,
people with different
accessibility needs.
And listen to what they have
to say with an open mind.
They have valuable
perspectives to share.
And how should you
test your apps?
We think that inclusive
design shouldn't just
be the job of a single
accessibility engineer
or a team of engineers.
It should be considered at
all phases of development,
from idea to design to
develop, all the way to launch.
So we've created
this mnemonic to make
it easy to promote inclusive
design process to all
of your developers.
And this mnemonic is this
Saturday morning test.
So imagine for a second you
woke up on a Saturday morning.
You're groggy.
You forgot your glasses
and your headphones.
And you just want to sit down in
a comfy chair and play some VR.
Well, this situation simulates
a significant portion
of different
accessibility needs.
And if you have perfect vision,
borrow someone else's glasses.
Try those on.
With these limitations, make
sure of these four things--
that controls are simple,
the text is readable,
the items are reachable,
and the audio is optional.
So again, accessibility
is an important lens
of inclusive design.
And let's dive
into the specifics
of how you can apply
inclusive design
to your immersive applications.
There's many
opportunities for actions.
And we can break these down
into four big categories
of accessibility needs--
mobility and dexterity,
visual, audio, and cognitive.
And we'll first cover
mobility and dexterity needs.
This is one of the
largest areas of impact
and one of the easiest to
make accommodations for.
Again, these include temporary
and permanent disabilities.
So the surface area
here is really large.
I'll run through it really
quickly, so hold on.
We have people with
one hand available
or you're just holding a cup of
coffee, people with shaky hands
or you drank too much coffee.
You have people
with limited finger
dexterity with challenges
grasping things and pressing
buttons, or people
just wearing gloves.
You have people with a
hard time bending down,
grabbing things off the
floor or up high off
shelves, and people
of different heights.
And then you have people
laying down, sitting down,
difficulties turning around.
Or perhaps they're
in an airplane seat.
And this is one of my
personal difficulties.
Ever since I started
using a wheelchair,
honestly, VR has
been a lot harder.
Tripping over the cord
used to be an issue.
It's a lot harder to step over
the cord with a wheelchair.
I also have trouble holding
things and moving around.
So if I'm holding
the two controllers
and trying to push my chair,
it's not really happening.
And I also have finger
dexterity problems,
where some of the muscles
in my hands just don't work.
So I have trouble
pressing some buttons.
Like, I'd jump back into
this game I used to play
and the enemies were
chasing after me.
And I can't press
that sprint button.
So just casually walking away.
Did end well there.
And I also have trouble
looking behind me
when things are all
the way back there.
So actually, this is a
good opportunity for us
to do a real exercise together.
So if I can get your
participation, please.
Just indulge me for a second
and suspend your disbeliefs.
Let's pretend we're Luke
Skywalker, Jedi in training,
holding a lightsaber
in front of you.
And there's a drone
flying around you,
shooting lasers at you.
Now, you must defend yourself
from this drone shooting lasers
at you.
So before you do it, try to
notice the things that happen
as you do this experiment.
So the drone's in front of you,
you're blocking these shots off
in front of you.
Come on.
Now, the drone's to your
right, so turn to your right.
Block those shots.
Don't feel shy about
your neighbors.
The drone's behind you.
Turn all the way behind you.
And then now, the
drone's to your left.
So I'm going to turn
270 degrees to my left.
And then now, the drone
is back in front of you.
So how did you do?
There are some good insights
we can pull out of this.
Although it's possible
to turn around and block
all of these shots,
it's difficult.
And if you're under
a time constraint,
it makes it impossible
to use this application.
And you want to really test
these situations yourself.
Don't feel silly.
These are very
valuable insights.
So not only does
this apply to me,
it applies to you sitting
in these conference chairs.
You don't want to whack your
neighbors with that lightsaber
or the person behind you.
And you want to
look silly sometimes
in these public situations.
And make sure that
these interactions
are useful in your app as
you do these experiments.
Now, let's dive
into some details
on how to make your
app more accessible.
So you saw that
example of Google Earth
VR allowing you to rotate
the space around you
with a controller.
Notice how there's also this
tunnel vision effect, where
it blurs out the surroundings
and creates this grid that
matches your real world
coordinates so you
don't get motion sickness.
And Google Earth VR also
allows you to move places
with the controller.
This is super
valuable for someone
trying to move around without
actually having the space
or sitting in a chair.
And it's also
valuable to give users
the control of
having incremental
versus smooth rotations
and movements.
This means snapping
those rotations
to 15 degree increments
versus smoothly going
around, or jumping
forward versus smoothly
gliding forward.
And this provides users
a choice of comfort
versus finer grained control.
And then let's
talk about height.
There's users of
different heights.
And it's super common in VR,
especially with little kids
these days getting
really excited
about this new technology.
My little sister
loves Job Simulator.
When it first came out,
she played it all the time.
But she couldn't reach some of
the items off the high shelves.
She's a 13-year-old
girl about this tall.
So one day, we
discovered that they
added this new shorter human
mode at the launch screen.
You turn it on and the world
shrinks down into a dollhouse.
You're feeling like this
10-foot giant inside this house.
And you can just reach
everything with ease.
And she's logged 50 something
hours on this game now.
Generally, you should design
to minimize for reaching
down low or up high.
Perhaps using a magnetic
hand to grab things
would be one way to solve this.
And interestingly enough,
with three degrees
of freedom controllers
like on the Daydream
View and the Mirage
Solo, the hardware
allows for more
accessible experiences.
There's no need to
reach up or down.
And custom controls,
allowing users
to choose what
works best for them.
So for me, having the ability
to remap that sprint button,
I can finally use
that game again.
And I play and I can
run away from enemies.
And giving users
assisted controls
is another way to help.
Some UI buttons are just
too small or not obvious
that they're interactable.
So using this bendy laser is
one way to solve that problem.
And shaky hands from
your morning coffee
won't be a problem
anymore either.
A lot of these concepts
are borrowed from gaming,
like assisted aiming
or assisted driving.
These are well-established
interactions in console games
already.
And they would be super valuable
for VR experiences as well.
And finally,
sensitivity adjustments
on different controls, so the
joystick rotations, et cetera.
It allows users to choose
between finer grained control
versus faster movement.
And now, let's talk about
mobile AR interactions.
Mobile AR borrows a
lot from mobile itself.
The interactions are
well defined for 2D UI.
But for 3D UI like
this, you want
to have adjustable
size and rotations
for different objects.
This is another great curb
cut opportunity in AR,
as it allows for people to
use your app in small spaces.
But it profoundly
impacts those using
your app stuck in a chair.
And for me, I can't really
see up high or reach very far.
And so I can move the objects to
places that works best for me.
And having large tap
targets, it forces
for simpler user
interfaces, friendlier UI,
and also makes
text more readable.
Generally, you want
the tap targets
to be at least finger size.
And finally, having
alternative gestures.
So an alternative to swiping
or shaking the phone,
having an extra tap target
to do these interactions
would be useful.
Now, on to visual impairments.
CHRISTOPHER PATNOE:
So as you look
towards visual
impairments, the groups
of people that
you'll be supporting
are people without glasses,
people with glasses, people
with high contrast needs or
[INAUDIBLE] deficiencies,
non-stereoscopic
vision, people who
are visually impaired or blind.
This covers an
awful lot of people
throughout different
phases of your life.
One of the most important
things you can do is have--
and you'll hear me say
this a couple of times--
multi-modal affordances.
Here, this is a matter
of having audio and text
at the same time.
If you have a narrative, have
it voiced over and written down.
This would help for people
with both audio impairments
and visual impairments.
The next is support for
large text and large fonts.
That is so much easier
to see if you can.
And the next one is a
contrary, good contrast,
in terms of your UI.
You probably can't
read all of the letters
there because I intentionally
made the contrast
bad to reproduce the situation.
Because if the contrast
is bad, it don't matter.
People can't see it.
And finally, if you
want to support people
with colorblindness, don't use
only color to support things
like health or progress.
Please use dedicated icons
or textures in addition
to the color because this
way, there's a different way
to tell the difference.
And always, please try to use
a colorblind safe palette.
Now, a lot of people
ask when I talk about--
I do work at accessibility
and AR and VR.
People ask, well, how do
blind people use AR or VR?
And I say, well, right
now it's really hard.
And hopefully this is
something that we all
can work on together.
Because at this time,
there is no support
in the major game engines
for accessibility services.
What happens is the UI in
three-dimensional space
are literally just
textures hanging out there
with a script attached.
There's no such thing as a
VR check box or text box.
It's just a floating
texture that
has a script that allows
it to act like a text box.
There's no window manager.
There's no way for
Accessibility Services
to understand how to navigate
what these things are.
So this is work that
needs to get done.
Now, this is not only true
for VR or 3D within AR,
this is actually true
within all 3D games as well.
So to that end, please don't
forget the Accessibility
Services glue code we mentioned
a little while ago from Zork,
github.com/zork.
Yes, it's that Zork.
And if you do want
this, please reach out
to the game manufacturers
and game engine developers.
Those [INAUDIBLE] of
indie game developers
is not just the unholy duo.
Reach out.
Ask for it so they can do it.
Moving on towards
hearing impairments.
Here, you are helping
people with impairments,
hearing impairments.
But also again, it's
the noisy environments
or the quieter
environments or people
without their headphones.
Here, again, this is that
multi-modal affordance
with the audio and video
happening at the same time.
Captions and narration, it's
the same idea, but slightly
different instances.
In captions, it's
normally video.
But in narration, it's
cut scenes of a game
or just any kind
of conversation.
Please include the captions
or narration in these things
so everyone can enjoy the
story that you're building.
And often if you have
avatars in either VR or AR,
we find captions are
often connected to a word
bubble or a thought bubble.
That's pretty useful, as long
as people know where to look.
So be careful with that.
But in terms of captions,
this is really important.
And unfortunately, not
all platforms support
closed captioning in VR.
YouTube VR has always
supported captions.
And the way YouTube VR does
it, it's called head locked.
So it's this little black
box with white letters.
And as you turn your head,
it spins around with you
because there's no way for us
to tell where for it to go.
But at least it's there.
But again, not all VR
platforms support this.
So if you have
video or if you're
using video in an application,
please burn it into the video.
It's not the best solution.
The best solution is
to support captions.
But if you can't,
please at least do this.
And when you're
doing it, there's
sort of two standards
that are most common.
One is a three up
like you see here.
It's 12, 4, and 7.
And the idea here is
to make sure there's
always some bit of
the captions available
in the peripheral vision
so you know that there's
something happening.
But what's happening
and becoming more common
is four up, sort of
north, south, east, west,
or all the same sides of a cube.
Put your captions in
these places and everyone
should be able to find them.
Now, there's this
new format called
VR 180, which we just announced
with the Lenovo Mirage.
This is a great camera.
And the way to make sure that
you have your captions, when
you go into YouTube, put
everything in a 16 by 9 crop.
And everything should
be visible there.
And that works just fine.
Moving on towards
cognitive impairments.
The people that you help
here are distracted users,
like parents, people
with difficulty
remembering or understanding
language, like parents
or foreign language speakers.
And what you do here is you want
to make your UI simple and easy
to use.
Now thiis isn't your Thoreau
simplify, simplify, simplify.
This is think about
the uses of your video,
the uses of your UI.
How do you guide someone
from one idea to the next?
Make it intuitive,
not just beautiful.
If you're talking
about a situation
where you have levels,
there's three things here
that are useful.
One is have a sandbox level.
For people who have
a hard time learning
or hard time
manipulating controls,
give them a place where
they can mess around
and learn how to use your
game or your experience
without having it impact
their ability to actually play
the game moving forward.
If you can't do that, make
sure you have good training
so you give people a safe
place, an opportunity
to learn how to build and
how to play your game,
how to use your interaction.
And then finally, have
different difficulty modes.
It's just standard
easy, medium, and hard,
but you don't want to be mean.
You don't want to tell anyone
you're going easy on them.
So I really like this story,
balanced and challenge
that some games
have talked about.
It's a lot nicer, but
it gets the same idea.
If you want someone to hear
your story, don't stop them.
Let them play to their ability.
And finally,
sometimes people just
can't get through the level.
So why should they be
stopped in the process
of getting through your story?
In this case, come
up with an auto pass.
Say, if you can't get
past it in 10 times,
ask, do you want to move
on to the next level
so they can see
what your story is?
Sometimes they'll say yes.
Sometimes they'll say no.
But why prevent them
from having the choice?
So auto pass is
a really nice way
to help people understand
and finish the work
that you've done.
Now, taking this step up from
sort of the game environments.
But an hour ago, we've
just announced my team
in the [INAUDIBLE]
accessibility has just announced
an application called Lookout.
What this is, it's
an AR application
that uses the camera and
it uses visual detection
of the world around you.
And it provides an
audio description
of the world around you.
So in the image
here, on the left
we have a picture of lavender.
And there's a caption
that says "Lavender."
And what you would hear is
"Lavender at 12 o'clock."
On the right-hand side, we
have a series of contexts.
There's three things
I want to talk
about here that are important.
That context menu is actually
surprisingly important
because unless we
know your context,
we don't know what to say.
Or more importantly, we
don't know what not to say.
If we don't know
what you care about,
we'll read everything to you.
If I had this right here, I'd
say person, person, person,
person, person, person.
And it's all correct,
but it doesn't matter.
So providing the
context gives you
an opportunity to actually
say the things that
matter in real time.
The second thing is a blind
user uses the camera very
differently than you expect.
It's really true.
When our testing, all
of our engineers--
because they're sighted--
would generally localize
the camera on the thing
that they wanted
to have recognized.
Yet, we went into user testing.
Boy, did we see really
different kinds of things.
So what we ended up
having to do is actually
capture all of the video as
things are moving around,
stitch it together into a very,
very large image, and then
[INAUDIBLE] on all of it.
Then we finally got the results
that we were looking for.
And finally,
spatialness, where are
things in space matters a lot.
If I'm describing
to you that there
is lavender in front of you,
it makes a big difference
if it's at 10 o'clock, 2
o'clock, or 12 o'clock.
So when you're trying to
guide someone to something,
that sense of space
and where things are
is really important in
terms of understanding
the world around you.
So in conclusion,
y'all can wake up now.
Please don't forget
these key points.
One, don't design for
yourself or your situation.
RAN TAO: Two, test,
talk, and listen.
Sit down and take the
Saturday morning test.
Check that controls are
simple, text is readable,
items are reachable,
audio is optional.
And think about the
different types of needs,
from mobility, visual,
auditory, and cognitive.
CHRISTOPHER PATNOE:
What are your curb cuts?
What is something
that you can do
that helps everybody, but has
a profound impact on someone
with disabilities?
And if you remember
nothing else,
you can always go to
AbleGamers includification.
This is a really great
resource if you want
a one-stop shop for everything.
RAN TAO: We want
to hear from you.
Provide feedback on this
session at that link.
And thank you so much
for attending our talk.
CHRISTOPHER PATNOE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]